welcome it's great to be here in this
transitional week in between time with
the flowers are blooming as we gather
again and maybe just a little sigh of
relief some of you still have one exam
left one task one thing left and then
you'll head out you'll see the boxes and
the UPS and all the you all lined up on
College Street it is that time again but
our community goes on our community
transitions to a new constitution and we
see each other again in a smaller group
and I think are able to embrace each
other in a very different way so welcome
their hearts hurt as they walked along
they felt it and ache inside each of
them they were just two of his followers
not the big names not the inner circle
not the 11 or the 12 just 21 with the
unfortunate name of Cleopas not one you
would probably name your child and the
other who didn't even merit mentioning
in the book he goes unnamed they
remembered as they walked how their
hearts had felt when they were with him
Art's full of light and joy hearts full
of his lived promise of hope of
forgiveness reconciliation and love they
had laughed they had even drunk wine
with the prostitutes and the tax
collectors they had played with the
children and they had believed in him
and because they had believed their
hearts hurt as they walked all those
dreams all those hopes and now nothing
he was dead and not just dead but
victimized and tortured and degraded
they thought he was a
when he rode that donkey into the city
just the week before but the Romans had
made very clear that to be king of the
jews was to be mocked and then destroyed
and some of their hearts hurt for what
they had held for just a few days before
everything had seemed to be coming
together God was coming back the kingdom
was coming now but see what had really
happened that the storm clouds had been
gathering all along that imperial power
had been plotting that one of their own
had been corrupted in the fickle crowds
who gave each new Messiah only ten
minutes to prove himself had turned
against him they'd walked to Jerusalem
anticipating triumph and the coming of
the kingdom of God but now their backs
were to Jerusalem their backs were to
that city and they were trudging away
down the hills to the Roman town of
Emmaus returning home but there was no
home anymore Henri Nouwen rights in many
ways we are like these two disciples we
know it when we dare to look into the
center of our being and their encounter
our lostness we have lost so much in
life and sometimes it seems that life is
just one long series of losses and so
our hearts like there's hurt hurt at the
lost dreams the innocence destroyed the
breathtaking violence the grim
certainties of death and aloneness but
then the stranger joined them and asked
them what they were talking about as
they walked along but they the story
says just stood still looking sad how do
you tell the story of the death of
someone you loved how do you tell it for
the first time you can hardly believe it
yourself you don't know what words to
use so you
out words that don't even seem real to
yourself he was a prophet who taught and
healed who changed the whole course of
their lives they had hoped he would be
the one and so they waited in Jerusalem
for three days just in case he'd said he
would rise again there were rumors they
even went to the tomb and it was empty
but they did not see him and so they
began the journey home that third day
and that's where they were when the
stranger joined them and their hearts
hurt for him for themselves and for the
world but all the stranger wanted to
talk about it seemed was religion he
blabbed on and on about how they were
fools and couldn't see what God was
doing they wanted to share their grief
with him and all he seemed to want to do
was to explain it away but it was
getting dark and they'd almost finished
the seven mile trudge and he was going
on somewhere but something in them they
didn't even know what it was made them
urge him to stay he'd heard their story
and even though he was some kind of
religious fanatic he'd been very nice
about it so they invited him to stay for
a meal and gave him a place to sleep it
was at that meal so much like the other
in that upper room that he took the
bread and blast it and broke it and as
they saw his hands tear that loaf and
say those familiar words they knew it
was him
why didn't we see who he was at first he
looked totally different but when we
thought back to our walk together maybe
not maybe he looked the same but we
couldn't believe it was him perhaps it
was just that all we could see was our
loss and our grief all we could do was
go over the story of his death again and
again all we could think of was how much
we missed him and we were missing him at
the same moment he was with us who says
there's no irony in religion it's easy
to live life counting our losses the
griefs the unrealized dreams the
betrayal by others the betrayals by
ourselves beloved maddening loved ones
dead before we could resolve what we
needed to resolve it's easy to blame God
for being missing in action and to blame
him so much that we can't see God when
God is walking beside us because our
hearts hurt that much but they should
burn Cleophus and the unnamed disciple
they asked why weren't our hearts
burning within us while he was teaching
us on the road I think the message today
is that hurt hearts can still burn burn
with the fire of the prophets that weep
by the waters of babylon burn with the
Justice of God that can be denied for a
moment but endures for a lifetime's burn
with the conviction that he died to lead
us through hell and out the other side
he didn't come back to say I'd never
died it wasn't real it was death real
bloody cruel and torturous they say that
when he appeared to the twelve there
were still holds in his hands and his
feet not healed but not bloody
glorified wounds our hearts are wounded
by life but we can choose to live in the
world those losses create a world of
regret of scarcity of cruel supposed
reality is a world of emptiness and
loneliness and grief or we can choose to
live in a world that doesn't deny those
losses but burns with a hope that is
that much more real and joyful for the
losses themselves we can leave our
wounds bloody or we can let them be
glorified we can leave our hearts hurt
or allow them to be set on fire Easter
is not for those who have never been
hurt never failed never lost Easter
surprisingly is not for starry-eyed
idealists the image the Bible gives of
the process of faith is of a refiners
fire if you know that area from Handel's
Messiah the self-serving illusions the
pride the ambition of life are all
burned away in life law that's leaving a
purity and intensity a calm strength
there's no room in Easter for dreamers
impressed by their own dreams there's no
room for pretty speeches or inspiration
with no grit behind it there's no room
for games or play-acting or pretend to
crises I guess that's what I missed this
week in the math celebrations of the
death of Osama bin Laden some sense that
we had been changed or refined by the
fire of our national experience I could
understand the exultation from college
students who had grown up in that long
and frightening shadow but I wondered
how do we show that our losses have
somehow deepened us or strengthened us
or refined us jesus meets us on the road
on our way back from Golgotha he sees
our sadness and he asks us to tell him
our story he reminds us of everything we
already know of God's creative love of
God's justice for the poor of God's
unwillingness to accept deceit or
worship of other gods he gathers us at
the table with our friends he takes the
bread and blesses it and breaks it and
gives it to us and is made known to us
again and he says receive my spirit go
and be me to the world amen